brazil is the one country in the world
which has the largest area covered by
forests so it is very very important for
Brazil and for Brazilians to learn and
understand about the forests the cloud
forest the rainforest the temperate
forests the cloud forest is essential
for the water supply in the region
because it harvests water from the air
so if the management of the cloud forest
is not done correctly then you might
have a water shortage action point cloud
forests are unique ecosystems they also
have a major importance in terms of
biodiversity because there is a lot of
endemic species that are current cloud
forests climate models they predict that
these regions they will become much
drier in the in the future mostly
because clouds will become more and more
rare we still don't have a good uns
understanding of how these changes will
actually impact cloud forest functions
understanding the Amazon is a very large
part of a much bigger problem which we
could say is understanding the earth or
earth system science and what we want to
be able to do is we want to understand
the earth well enough and all these
component systems so that we can
understand what the implications of
climate change are and then we can
communicate that and we can make that
sort of a human challenge to ask the
question okay we see where we're going
what are we going to do for many many
scientific project is probably still
done in the old-fashioned way that they
have graduate student go to the field
once a week to either download the data
or just for many cases copy them down
and type it into Excel afterwards for
the analysis think the benefit of
network sensor is to be able to stream
that data seamlessly from sensors
through the network into the system have
the system manage that data and
visualize it in real time so the
scientists can
observe what's happening they can
directly perform feedback into the
actual deployment to either change it or
sample a different rate to observe
different things that will give this
real-time feedback and opportunity of
getting high fidelity data for the
period of interest target is important
component of what happens in this
environmental system but you don't
actually measure fog directly which you
measure is the temperature dropping and
the Sun is no longer shining and
humidity has gone way up and it's not
raining so your rain sensors are saying
nope there's no rain and so you say the
combination of these things means that
there is fog this is a small scale study
in terms of space but it's very data
intensive in terms of many different
kinds of sensors the red one is a
central heater and these two are thermal
couples and the thermocouples they have
sensors in two different parts of the in
the radio profile of the wood and I
think these potentially will help us to
resolve for the whole tree like carbon
uptake on a daily basis we are using the
azure cloud as a sort of a way of doing
our data management without actually
having to operate own and operate
physical computers so we're putting
cyber infrastructure or data management
tools in the Microsoft cloud and that's
a good way for us to help the scientists
manage their data sets because their
data sets are very complex and when they
can manage their data sets then they can
get to asking scientific questions more
effectively chorus is I'd say one
instance of a very broad class of
applications for example from say health
care you attach sensors to people the
aldolase to be monitored get data to a
centralized location that physicians can
take a look and analyze it and provide
feedback there are so many of these
applications that pretty much share the
same kind of architecture and can
benefit from the research result we get
from
cooperation we will learn things like
which kinds of data we did not measure
with all those sensors that is something
that will impact knowledge about the
environment knowledge about forests and
forest they are important for us and for
the world
you